voilà bouge un grand grand oh le bordel
c'est immonde ce truc
ah Monsieur non les barbus rentrent par
la porte de droite s'il vous plaît les
barbus on est obligé de réguler le flux
du magasin c'est marqué barbu à l'entrée
là juste la porte là pour chanter ici
c'est les femmes blondes ici merci
Monsieur ici c'est les hommes sont
lunettes vous prenez l'entrée des hommes
à la nuit à vous verrez marqué le sigle
lunettes ah bon on est obligé vous aviez
la
moustache en rentrant monsieur
vous l'avez pas prise dans le magasin la
moustache
il ressort vous l'aviez en rentrant
merci Monsieur d'accord Monsieur Xavier
des lunettes en rentrant d'accord
vous aviez un échameaux d'accord
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui piquent les femmes
des autres dans les magasins alors on
est obligé de contrôler
c'est à vous c'est payé
cet article il est payé ok merci
donc tu l'emmènes
je lui ai demandé quelque chose
je me gratte
je me gratte une sorte des paquets de ce
que vous voulez non c'est bon j'ai tout
payé
non regardez je sais vous avez des
plombages parce que des fois ça fait ça
quand les gens ouvre la bougeoir ouvre
la boue
encore ok à vous montrer vos plombages à
la caméra comme ça il y aura pas de
voyez la caméra là allez ouvre la bouche
film voilà c'est des plombages à
l'arrière piqué la dame ouvrez la bouche
regardez voilà le boxon là-dedans
mettez la main dans la bouche et
repasser
la casquette ah bon on va passer
repasser non
mettez-la sur la tête sur la tête
repasser la
casquettes maintenant elles sont
plombées comme ça
finalement j'ai pas été embauché à plein
temps ils ont dit que j'étais pas assez
con ah c'est un métier faut être très
con surveillant
tout ce qui passe et là tu tombes sur
Baffie quoi
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu